People who like Pewds...
...People who don't like Pewds...
...Making fun of Pewds.
Why am I here?
*deep thoughts*
I'm just singing the LWIAY intro.
Because people like when I did it last episode.
*laughs*
Welcome to LWAAAH!
*guttural noise*
I might be editing this one as well.
That is true.
Brad is not here. *Ha!! Who's laughing now?!*
Brad 2 Died... *Press F for Respect.*
...and here I am.
Who nee- I need a video the same day.
Guys...!!
I don't wanna edit this! I'm already tired.
GODDAMIT!!
Roll the Intro...
...Felix.
Goddamn. I'm retarded.
*laughs*
Yes!
I think...
I still have the car.
I think it's illegal for me to drive that car.
But we need a part two.
This was a better time.
Interesting hair style from Marzia.
I wish, okay? I wish Marzia would go back to this look.
She looked way better.
Nice try. But you know what we want.
*frustrated pause*
It's so great to be part of a channel where... the entire universe just hates you.
*chuckle*
It's like "People who don't like Pewds"...
..."People who don't like Pewds"...
Here I am, everybody!
What you meant to say was "People who like Pewds" and "People who don't like Pewds.
And trust me I'm starting to not like you either, Pewds!
Sixty-five million subscribers.
Going. Strong.
*Laughing*
"Felix reaction to memes with Marzia be like:"
Oh my god. It continues.
"Pewds eats a picture of him"
Right! So, he didn't complete it.
He wrote me on Twitter saying "No, this is fake".
"I haven't done it yet."
So, no.
Uhh, "Lego Star Wars Gameplay".
It's coming, guys. It's coming.
"Get an Alexa"
Alexa!
*Alexa doesn't respond*
Hello?
*Alexa still doesn't respond*
GODDAMMIT!
*Alexa plays music that cuts off randomly*
*music abruptly stops*
No.
Don't ever do that again.
Alexa! Never do that again!
*Alexa takes a minute to compose herself*
Alexa: Sorry, I'm not sure.
*Angery gibberish*
There you go. You can check that one off.
"Play his guitar"
Okay. Alright. Okay. Alright.
*Clap*
This guitar has been in the background in my videos for too long.
It's missing a string and I just haven't been bothered to fix it.
I could easily fix it.
*Clap* If. *Clap* This. *Clap* Video gets five-hundred-thousand likes
I will play Despacito on guitar as all-- as promised.
Next week, okay?
Okay?
Alright?
Okay? Okay.
*silence*
*Alexa suddenly starts playing music*
WHAT THE F--
"Nine year-olds. Brad and Sive's funny editing."
"Nine year-old's. Felix sh--"
Thank you so much.
I make a Pewdiepie propaganda poster.
Okay.
This is epic.
I like this.
*Clap clap*
I like this a lot.
*Chuckles*
"YouTube. Me."
"Can You Cast Obsidian?"
*like Alinity* Can we cast Obsidian?!
Yeah. This video's everywhere.
Can you stop recommending it to me?
Stop it. No one cares about "Obsibdian".
*realizes he mispronounced obsidian*
What was that? What was that, Felix?
Obsibdian
Alright. That's cool.
"Kids.. have crushes"
"Men.. have girlfriends"
"Legends have... depression"
*awkward silence*
Alexa, this is so sad.
Can we play Despacito number five-thousand-five-hundred and nine?
*Alexa processes in silence*
*Alexa stopped listening*
There's no Despacito five-thousand-five-hundred and nine.
*gentle sob*
Ay! "Now we can create the 22nd biggest country in the world.
This is really cool.
Finally something positive on this LWIAY
"I wonder how many of those people are dead."
MOVING ON!
"Reacting to his most popular video"
"Reacting to his MOST UNpopular video"
You just got myself a video idea.
I like you, whoever did this.
*clap* Very good.
Alex-ex-ex-ex-ex-ex-ex-ex--
Okay. Alright.
"When you remember you left Brad 1 and Brad 2 chained to the basement without food"
It happens, guys. It happens
That's probably why I have to edit this video.
*laughing*
"Brad 1 and 2 laughing when they see that PewDiePie has to edit his own video but then sees how much everyone enjoyed Felix's shh editing"
"When Marzia--"*chuckles*
"When Marzia tells y--" yo-- I gue--
I guess you guys figured me out, huh?
You figured me out.
Yes, I play Minecraft.
What are you going to do, you nine year-old virgins?
*chuckle*
"You're fired"
"You're unable to work here again"
"You're jobn't"
Or, my favorite
"You're promoted to customer"
*clap clap* Well done.
*chuckles and claps*
It's not bad memes this week.
I have actually
laughing at them.
"I went to the highest mountain in Sweden just to t-pose and rep merch."
What an absolute mad lad.
Congratulations
Check out merch. Only available four more days.
Oh wait. "The nine year-olds are getting younger"
*Pewdiepie ending theme plays* (an actual footage of me jamming to pewds outro)
Awww. He loves it.
*baby giggling*
"Hey, guys. I'm having some trouble with my YouTube Red membership. Can you help?"
"We'd like to help. Could you share more details about the issue? We'll look into it."
"I can't seem to find season 2 of Scare Pewdiepie. Can you help?"
*clap*This *clap* is so *clap* great.
If this gets five-thousand likes I will leak Scare Pewdiepie Season 2 on DailyMotions, everybody. 😱😱 (ohhh shet im not ready)
*high pitched voice* Well, is he really going to do it?
Hmmmm
Five-thousand likes and you'll find out.  ͡(° ͜ʖ ͡°)
"I met Pewdiepie five days ago."
"I got roped into watching my 3 month old niece while my sister got her hair done."
"So there I am,  sitting in the waiting area of a hair salon and who walks in but effing Pewdiepie himself?" (dont swear (｀Д´)
"I was nervous as shhht, and just kept looking at him and he was sitting there with his phone and waited but"
"was too scared to say anything to him.
"Pretty soon my niece started crying,"
" and I'm trying to quiet her down because I didn't want her to bother Pewds, but she wouldn't stop."
I-- I was there. I remember this, actually. (me too, I also was there. I'm the hair straightener (´∀`)
"Pretty soon he gets up and walks over."
"He started running his hands through her hair (＾▽＾) and asked what was wrong (・о・)
"I replied that she was probably hungry
or something."
"So Pewds put down his phone, picked up my niece, and lifted his shirt. (FBI OPEN UP (ﾉಠдಠ)ﾉ︵┻━┻
"H--uh-- He breast fed her right there" (lets all take a moment of silence ఠ_ఠ)
*struggling to keep reading* (・・；)
"in the middle of the hair salon." ⊙△⊙
"Chill guy, really nice about it.  (≧▽≦)
"Would let him breast feed my niece again." 👌😫👅💦
*awkward silence* inner pewds: wtf did i just read
(꒪⌓꒪) . 10/10 would win Oscar.
"The Italian stereotype is true!
"This is so sad" *while laughing* (alexa play italy national anthem)
I love how many people pointed this out in the video.
"Five lies that girls tell:" (NUMBER 5 WILL SHOCK YOU 😱😱)
"I'm fine" ( ￣＾￣)
"I'm not jealous" (ಠ⌣ಠ)
"I'm over him" (╥_╥)
"Sure we can be friends" (♡ >ω< ♡)
"I'm Poppy Harlow and I don't normally share my opinion"
(ﾉಠдಠ)ﾉ︵┻━┻
"YouTube Recommendations"
*mocking Alinity* "Can You Cast Obsidian?"
*reading comments* "That video is always appearing to me and I'm like wtf I don't even watch stuff related with that."
Okay. ｖ(⌒ｏ⌒)ｖ
I'm gonna-- I'm gonna title this video (　･`ω･´) *thinks very hard*
and thumbnail it exactly the same. *genius pewds strikes again*
.*:ﾟ（｀・ω・´）ゝﾟ:*.
And I need you guys help to trick YouTube algorithms and viewers. (cmon 9 year old armys) (*＞ｖ＜)ゞ*゜+
That, that is what they're watching.
So, everyone comment in the video saying "wow, that is epic."
"You can actually cast obsidian" *while laughing*
C'mon, guys. I need the views.
Help a brother out. C'mon.
"Hard to swallow pills!"
"The Marzia idea was good but we need to stop making demands because it makes
"the content even less original and the subreddit sucks now"
It's always sucked. Don't worry about it.
"Marzia hosts LWAIY"
"It wasn't Brad"
"Pewds edited his own video"
"No A.S.S. outro"
Twenty-thousand upvotes!
You always find something, don't you?
You-- ohh. You sly little.
"A Swedish guy that speaks English with an American accent,
lives in Brighton, UK with his Italian girlfriend,
and is wearing an American flag shirt
and a Russian hat! *pewds ends racism* Σ(･口･)
His neighbors much be so confused."
(´･_･`)
Mr. World-Wide, everybody!
Somehow, I don't know how,
the most upvoted Reddit out of all time on this, uh, Reddit
happened last week and it's this one
and it has thirty-thousand upvotes.
"If you sway-- face swap this scene from Incredibles 3 (its incredibles 2, you uncultured twat) you get Casey Neistat-" *cuts off laughing*
"and Logan Paul"
*can't hold in his laughter* (^▽^;)
*clap* Great. Great-- Great meme, everybody.
Thank you guys for watching this video!
I had a lot of fun editing it.
Yeah.
I'm glad it's over.
Thank you guys for submitting all the memes.
Thank you guys for sixty-five-million.
Thank you guys for buying the merch.
Thank you guys for becoming a joiner.
Now, for real. I know I always sound sarcastic but, uh
umm (￣ー￣；
ehh, thank you *pfft* (what was that?? (・о・)
You guys are awesome.
I love that we have this Reddit
That we can just share jokes and ideas.
Just know that I do appreciate ya.
Even though y-you make fun of me, even though you tr-- step on me,
even though you spit in my face, I still love you.
Alright. This is getting too sappy.
Good bye!
(Aww pewds we love ya too, you know? You always made us entertained, keep up the good work, buddy!!)
Someone: Infinity war is the best crossover ever!!
Brad 3: Hold my beer *puts ASS outro and dope ass outro song in the same video*
Marvel is shaking, this ends fanwars, cleared my acne and everybody is SHOOKETH.
bUt cAn yOu dO tHissSSsSS?? (ಥ_ʖಥ)
HOWS IT GOING BROS????  .*:ﾟ（｀・ω・´）ゝﾟ:*.
*eminem needs to take notes 📝*
Sorry, can't do the subs (Ｔ▽Ｔ) because the rap are too fast ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
I'm done with this (ﾉ｀□´)ﾉ⌒┻━┻ past the 🎤 to Edgar
ok bye losers